وهذه ساعه اخباريه جديده ايضا من العربيه
نتابع فيها تداعيات زلزال تركيا وسوريا
بالاضافه الى تطورات ادوليه والعربيه
دخول اول قافله مساعدات امميه عبر معبر
باب السلامه الحدوديه بين تركيا ومناطق
سيطره المعارضه في شمال سوريا
انقذوا سيده تركيا تبلغ من العمر 77 عاما
بعد تسعه ايام من الزلزال مع تواصل عمليات
رفع الانقاض
ولدينا ايضا روسيا ترد على تقارير تيمها
باحتجاز اطفال اوكرانيين بالقوه وتقول
انها استقبلتهم مع اسرهم بعد فرارهم من
القصف
الجيش الامريكي يعلن اسقاط طائره مسيره
ايرانيه الصنع في سوريا كانت تحاول
استطلاع قاعده دوريات في شمال شرق البلاد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى تفاصيل هذه النشره تتواصل في
تركيا وسوريا عمليات رفع الانقاض فيما
تستمر حصيله الضحايا الزلزال بالارتفاع اذ
بلغت اكثر من 39 الف قتيل في كلا البلدين
هذا وقد دخلت اول قافله مساعدات امميه عبر
معبر باب السلامه الحدوديه بين تركيا
ومناطق سيطره الفصائل المعارضه المعارضه
في شمال سوريا وتتالف القافله من 11 شاحنه
مقدمه من المنظمه الدوليه للهجره التي
افادت بان المساعدات تشمل مستلزمات
وبطنيات وسجاد
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
بوتيريج اطلق نداء طارئا لجمع نحو 400
مليون دولار لمساعده ضحايا الزلزال في
سوريا على مدى ثلاثه اشهر مشيرا الى ان
المنظمه تعمل ايضا على اطلاق نداء مماثل
لمساعده تركيا
الامم المتحده تطلق نداء لجمع 300
مليون دولار لمساعده ضحايا الزلزال في
سوريا هذا المبلغ سيغطي فتره ثلاثه اشهر
نحن في المراحل الاخيره من اطلاق نداء
مماثل لمساعده تركيا الامم المتحده قدمت
50 مليون دولار من المساعدات فورا بعد
وقوع الزلزال من صندوق المسؤوليات العاجله
نحتاج اكثر من ذلك
وفي اطار المساعدات الانسانيه ينتظر ان
تصل الى حلب السوريه طائره الاغاثه
السعوديه الثانيه وهي تاسعه ضمن الجسر
الجوي السعودي الذي يقوم بنقل المساعدات
الاغاثيه لمتضرر الزلزال في سوريا وتركيا
وتحمل طائره اكثر من خمسه واربعين طنا من
المستلزمات والمعدات الطبيه وح الاطفال
وخيام الايواء والمواد الغذائيه وينتظر ان
تتوجه طائره اغاثيه ثالثه الى حلب يوم
الاربعاء كما تتوجه الى مطار غازي عنتاب
طائره هي العاشره ضمن الجسر الجوي باشراف
مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه والشركاء حامله اطنان من
المستلزمات الطبيه والاسره والخيام
الايوائيه وسلاسل الغذائيه الطائر التي
وصلت
صباح هذا اليوم تحمل على متنها لوازم تشمل
خيام وبطانيات واحتياجات الاسر الضروريه
وكذلك مواد وسلال غذائيه وادويه واجهزه
طبيه ومستلزمات طبيه هذه هي الطائره
الاولى
ولدينا عدد من الطائرات سوف
يغادر خلال الساعات القادمه
بجدوله منظمه من الرياض الى حلب
للوصول المساعدات الى الاسر والمجتمع
الاكثر تضررا في سوريا
دكتور عبد الله ربيعه اكد ايضا للعربيه ان
الفرق المعنيه في مركز الملك سلمان تدرس
امكانيه اعاده اعمار المناطق المنكوبه
جراء الزلزال المدمر
المساعدات السعوديه بالعكس كامله وشامله
نحن الان نستجيب
الاحتياجات الضروريه والعاجله جدا لانقاذ
الحياه كما شاهدتم فرق انقاذ اطباء كوادر
صحيه فرق متطوعين مواد اغاثيه مواد طبيه
اجهزه كذلك بطانيات خيام وكذلك اجهزه
تدفئه يتبعها كذلك الوجود على الارض يوجد
فرق تقييم للاحتياج ما بعد الاحتياجات
الطارئه من ضمنها كذلك
انشاء اولا ماوى مؤقت يتبعه كذلك ان شاء
الله من خلال الدراسات التي تقوم بها
الفرق المعنيه في مركز الملك سلمان
بدراسه امكانيه كذلك
اعاده الاعمار
ومع توالي الايام بعد زلزال تطفو على سطح
الرخام قصص وذكريات لمن ماتوا تحت هذه
الانقاض صور واغراض وسقط حياتهم وتحولت
الى ذكرى للنجينه من الكارثه مفرد العربيه
يرسل لنا المشهد من كهرمان مرعش
توقفت العاصفه في هذا الموقع في كهرمان
شاه ذهب رجال الانقاذ ورجال الاسعاف
والمتسمرين لايام طويله في هذا الموقع الا
ان شيئا بقي على هذا الكرسي ذكريات
ولاحظات سعيده ليسرق مكونه من سته اشخاص
قضت في هذا الموقع لم ينجوا منهم احد ولكن
ذكرياتهم بقت للماره الذين يسلكون هذا
الطريق يتسمرون امام الصور امام الذكريات
وامام لحظات وثقوها بانفسهم وضعت في هذا
الموقع جميعها استخرجت الا هم خرجوا الى
المقابر الجماعيه اشاهد بعض الصور التي
تداولوها فيما بينهم يبدو ان هذه الاسره
كانت تعمل في التجاره حتى كتب احدهم لاحد
اخر اللهم احفظ هذه التجاره المركزيه لكن
تجارتهم انتهت وبقيت ذكرياتهم في هذا
الموقع في كهرمان مرعش عبد المحسن الحربي
لقناته العربيه والحدث كهرمان مرش
عرضت مدينه حلب ثاني اكبر المدن السوريه
لاضرار جسيمه في الارواح والبنى التحتيه
حيث لحقت الاضرار بابرز المعالم التاريخيه
للمدينه وبعضها يعود لالاف السنين نتابع
الضرر لحق باهم المعالم التاريخيه للمدينه
ابرزها قلعه حلب
قوه الزلزال هدمت اجزاء من اسوار القلعه
وتسببت بتشققات في جدرانها
كذلك تضررت مناره الجامع الايوبي ومساجد
وكنائس يعود بعضها الى العهد العثماني
امتدت اثار الزلزال الى المدينه القديمه
وبواباتها المتعدده باب انطاكيا من جهه
الغرب كان اكثر ابواب المدينه الاثريه
تضررا الدمار لحق ايضا بالاسواق التاريخيه
كسوق الجوخ وسوق خان الوزير ومحلهما
التجاري
ونبقى مع حضراتكم في متابعه الاوضاع
الانسانيه في ريف حلب وينضم الينا الصحفي
احمد ابو لؤي مرحبا بك احمد كنا نتحدث في
خدمه اخباريه سابقه عن وصول بعض المساعدات
ولكن في الوقت ذاتي هناك وضع انساني صعب
كيف تبدو الصوره لديك احمد مع مرور
الساعات وتدفق هذه المساعدات وكيف هي
احوال المنكوبين
نعم رشا بدايه يعني بعد مرور تسعه ايام
على كارثه الزلزال الذي ضرب مناطق شمالي
غرب البلاد طبعا
ومنذ ايام يعني كما علم الجميع اعلنت فرق
الدفاع المدني على انتهاء عمليات البحث
وانقاذ العالقين بعد انقطاعهم لامل وصول
اي نوع من اي انواع المساعدات كاليات
كاجهزه حراريه لاخراج العالقين سواء ما
زالوا على قيد الحياه او من وافتهم المنيه
او ادخال جرافات وغيرات يعني
وبداوا بعمليات البحث والانتشار بعد شبه
انعدام لوجود احياء طبعا الضحايا بلغت او
تجاوزت
2270 حاله وفاه عموما شمال غرب سوريا
واكثر من
اصابه طبعا الحيه الاكثر اخذته مدينه
جنديرس هي التي كانت تعتبر المنطقه
المنكوبه اخذت الحدث الاكبر منطقه جنديرس
في ريف عفرين شمال حلب حيث وصلت اعداد
الوفيات الى 513
والمباني المهدمه من
اجمالي العدد الكلي يعني العدد الكلي من
المباني المهمه كان 550 يعني اخذت ايضا
الحيز الاكبر 220 المبنى طبعا اعود قليلا
لوضع العائلات يعني اوضاع ماساويه هنالك
الالاف من المباني التي تصضعت نجد اليوم
الاف من العائلات في الطرقات ما سالوا في
الاراضي الوعيره منهم من يعني تم مخيمات
مفترض ان هناك شحنات من المساعدات وصلت
تتضمن هذه الخيانه
نعم نعم التحدث عن هذا الموضوع يعني
منهم من بدايه قبل وصول المساعدات يعني
بجهود فرديه لاعداد بعض الثياب لكن لا
تكفي بالنسبه للمساعده يوم امس دخلت
قافله مكونه من اذاعه شاحنه مقدمه
منخده يعني السلامه
في مدينه بغداد شمال حلب وقبل يومين او
ثلاثه ايام دخلت يعني
مساعدات مقدمه ايضا ايداع الشاحنه مقدمه
من المملكه العربيه السعوديه لكنها فريده
نوعا ما لانها يوجد بداخلها خيام يوجد
بداخلها مواقف طبيه يعني تعتبر افضل من
غيرها ويتم توزيعها على فئه من المنكوبين
لكن رغم كل ذلك يعني
يدخل اصبح او يتدفق يعني
من المساعدات حتى المنطقه الشرقيه فزعه
العشائر يعني اثقل ايضا مساعدات وشواحن
محمله بالبطانيات والفرشات
والموارد الغذائيه وغيرها لكن اليوم
مناشدات
[موسيقى]
الناس الذين هجروا لان هذا التهجير
بفعل الكوارث الطبيعيه ليس الاول يعني
هنالك تهجير سابق بعمل النظام السوري يعني
غالبيه المهجرين الذين هجروا اليوم
سابقا من مناطقهم سواء الغوطه الشرقيه
وغيرها
صعب وقاتلين بمناطق ريف حلب
ومناطق ارياف ادلب يعني مع الاسف وايضا
هنالك من القاطنين من هجروا ايضا بفعل
الكارثه الطبيعيه للزلزال الذي حصل او
الذي هجره
يعني الالاف من العائلات اليوم رسالتهم او
مناشداتهم للمجتمع الدولي للمنظمات
الدوليه للدول التي تعاهدت
لمسانده الشعب السوري هو تفعيل
مشاريع يعني شقق سكنيه يعني ان كانت شقه
العديد من النقاط الانسانيه الحرجه
والصعبه
احمد ابو لؤي من ريف حلب شكرا لك
تتواصل في تركيا وسوريا عمليات رفع
الانقاذ فيما تستمر حصيله ضحايا الزلزال
بالارتفاع اذ بلغت اكثر من 39 الف قتيل في
كلا البلدين كما ذكرنا لحضراتكم لكننا
بصيص الامل لا يزال موجود لدى عناصر
الانقاذ اذ تم انتشال امس اربعه ناجين من
تحت الانقاض في تركيا منهم سيده على قيد
الحياه وتبلغ من العمر 77 عاما في اديمان
التركيه بعد نحو 212 ساعه من الزلزال
السلام
وفي ادمان ايضا استطاعت فرقه لانقاذ
التركيه انتشار طفل يبلغ من العمر 11 عاما
وذلك من تحت الانقاض بعد ان بقى هناك
لاكثر من 270 ساعات
[موسيقى]
كما تمكنت قوات الدفاع المدني في مدينه
هاتاي من انقاذ اثنين من افراد عائله
مكونه من سبعه اشخاص بقيت محاصره تحت
الانقاض لتسعه ايام
[موسيقى]
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان قال ان قوه
زلزال الاخير في بلاده تعادل مئات القنابل
الذريه واعلن اردوغان ارتفاع حصيله ضحايا
الزلزال الى اكثر من خمسه وثلاثين الفقيل
جميعه علماء الزلازل اتفقوا على ان
الزلزال الاخير كان من اقوى الزلازل التي
حدثت في العالم وقدر قوته بقوه مئات
القنابل الذريه نحو 13 الف جريح يتماثلون
للشفاء في المستشفيات يعتبر حجم وشده
الزلازل ومدى تدميرها ظاهره طبيعيه
استثنائيه اتمنى الرحمه لكل القتلى الذين
يبلغ عددهم
35,418 من مواطني بلدي واتمنى شفاء
المصابين الذين تم انقاذهم الذين يبلغ
عددهم وخمسه الاف وخمسمائه وخمسه جرحى
ونبقى في ناردا في غازي عنتاب الزميل
زيدان زنكلو هو منذ الصباح يرصد لنا
الاجواء في هذه المنطقه التي اصبحت الان
مركزا لواء المنكوبين بالاضافه الى رزه
للطرق الرئيسيه التي تعتبر شريان حياه
بالنسبه لمدن الجنوب التركيه مرحبا بك
مجددا زيدان تفضل
مرحبا مجددا رشا كما تشاهدين نحن الان
انتقلنا من موقع الى موقع اخر في نورداغ
النشاط السابقه كنا قرب مخيمات الايواء او
المخيمات التي انشاتها هيئه الطوارئ
والكوارث التركيه افاد لايواء سكان نورداغ
والقرى المحيطه بها الان انتقلت الى احد
الاحياء الرئيسيه في نورداغ كما تشاهدون
هذا الحي بات كتلا من الركام طبعا انتقلت
الى هذا الحي بعد ان انتهت اعمال
البحث والانقاذ عن ناجين ستبدا قريبا خلال
ايام عمليات ازاله هذه الانقاض حي كامل
دمرت وبات اكواما من الركام والكتل
الخرسانيه والابنيه التي في الخلف ايضا هي
ابنيه غير صالحه للسكن طبعا مع الاسف يعني
نشاهد حجم الضرر الكبير هنا انتقلت الى
هذا الحي للحديث عن احصائيات رسميه بدات
تظهر مؤخرا خلال الساعات الماضيه
كالتصريح الرئيس التركي اكتمال العمل مع
15 الف مبنى مدمر من اصل 19000 مبنى مدمر
اي بقاء 4000 مبنى ما زالت هناك محاولات
للوصول لوصول او محاولات فرق الانقاذ
مستمره في تلك المباني في الولايات العشر
المتضرره طبعا تم تصنيف يعني اتحدث الان
في الارقام الرسميه تم تصنيف سبعه واربعون
الفناء تضم اكثر من 200 الف بيت او وحده
سكنيه كمنازل منهاره او منازل بحاجه الى
هدم عاجل او منازل تعرضت لاضرار بليغه
بالتالي نتحدث عن ان
حجم الاضرار في المباني ما بين المباني
منهاره او متصدعه او متشققه وفيها اضرار
كثيره بلغ 47,000 بناء في الولايات العاشر
الكبرى طبعا هذا يعني ان هذه المباني
بالكامل غير صالحه للسكن حتى
حتى التي لم تنهار هي غير صالحه للسكن هذا
يعني ان هناك حاجه لبناء 47 الف بناء جديد
ليستوعب اكثر من 200 او يضم اكثر من 200
الف شقه سكنيه والرئيس التركي يوم امس
تحدثه عن بدء حكومه الحكومه التركيه او
استعداد الحكومه التركيه لبناء اكثر من 30
الف وحده سكنيه ابتداء من مارس القادم اي
ان مرحله اعاده الاعمار ستبدا خلال فتره
قريبه جدا والحديث ايضا عن الارقام
الرسميه نتحدث
سؤال يتعلق به هل تمت او انتهت عمليات
رفع الانقاض والبحث عن الناجين في هذه
المناطق لانها تبدو خاليه تماما الان هناك
فقط اثار هل انتهت فرق الانقاذ من هذه
المناطق
نعم كما ذكرت يعني في عموم المناطق
المنكوبه في هذا الحي الذي نتواجد فيه نعم
انتهت عمليات البحث والانقاذ كنا زرنا هذا
الحي قبل ثلاثه ايام وكانت فرق الانقاذ
تواصل العمل وصورنا وكنا في مباشر من هذا
الحي قبل ثلاث ايام على شاشه العربيه لكن
اليوم عندما زرنا هذا الحي مجددا العمليات
قد انتهت وبحسب ما ابلغنا
من بقي هنا من السكان الذين ياتون الى
زياره هذا الحي انتهت عمليات الانقاذ قبل
حوالي يومين طبعا سكان بما ان بدانا نتحدث
عن الاهالي نتحدث عن متضررين الزلزال
متضرره الزلزال يقيمون حاليا نحن نتحدث
فقط في نورداغ في مخيمات عده شاهدناها في
النشرات الماضيه هنا في قرب مدينه نوردا
حيث اقيمت عشرات المخيمات لاستضافه
استضافه متضررين الزلزال الذين بقوا
الماوى نتيجه تدمر غالبيه منازل نورداغ
هذه المدينه التي تقع في ولايه غازي عنتاب
لكن هذا هذه المخيمات رشا هي مخيمات مؤقته
سيتم خلال فتره قصيره جدا نقل سكان هذه
المخيمات الى اماكن ايواء مؤقته نتحدث عن
السكن الجامعي وعن الفنادق وهي الخطه
الحكوميه لمعالجه هذه الازمه لاسيما ان
الجامعات توقفت عن العمل وبدات مرحله
ستبدا مرحله التعليم عن بعد حتى الصيف
اشكرك
الصباح وهو ينفرد بهذه الصور الحصريه
للعربيه من نور التركيه التي اصبحت مركزا
لايواء المنكوبين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد كشفت دراسه امريكيه ان
روسيا تحتجز اكثر من سته الاف طفل من
اوكرانيا في مخيمات بهدف استعابهم وتبنيهم
في اجراءات قد تشكل جريمه حرب حسب الدراسه
اوضح تقرير ان روسيا تنقل منذ بدايه الحرب
اطفالا لا تتجاوز اعمار بعضهم اربعه اشهر
الى ثلاثه واربعين معسكر في انحاء روسيا
من اجل ما يسمى التعليم الوطني والمتعلق
بالجيش الموالي لروسيا وفق التقرير الصادر
عن مركزيه للابحاث والممول من وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه
يوضح تقرير صدر اليوم عن مركز الابحاث
الانسانيه بجامعه يل جهود روسيا المنهجيه
والحكوميه الواسعه لنقل الالاف من الاطفال
اوكرانيا بشكل دائم الى مناطق خاضعه
لصادره الحكومه الروسيه عبر شبكه من 43
معسكر ومنشاه اخرى
سفاره روسيا لدى الولايات المتحده ردت على
هذه الاتهامات بالقول ان روسيا استقبلت
اطفالا اجبروا على الفرار مع اسرهم من
القصف في اوكرانيا وقلت السفاره ان روسيا
تبذل قصارى جهدها للحفاظ على القصر في
الاسر وفي حالات غياب او وفاه الوالدين
والاقارب يوضع الايتام تحت وصايا
كشف صحيفه
عن تكدس معدات ومركبات واسلحه امريكيه في
ميناء شمال المانيا وذكرت الصحيفه ان وجهه
المعدات ما زالت غير معلومه مرجحه امكانيه
توجيهها الى اوكرانيا او تحديث مخزون
العتاد العسكري لدى بولندا ونقلت الصحيفه
عن مصادر المانيه ان شحنه تحتوي على
مركبات برادلي وانه يجري نقلها الى قاعده
في مدينه المانيه لتدريب القوات
الاوكرانيه عليها
ومع اغتراب بالذكرى السنويه الاولى على
بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا لا يزال الوضع
متقلبا بين رغبه روسيه في التقدم واستماته
اوكرانيه في الدفاع والبحث عن السعاده
الاراضي المفقوده ووسط هذا الشد والجذب
تبرز مؤشرات عديده على ان الفتره القادمه
ستكون حاسمه للغايه على الميدان وفق عده
مصادر اخرها تقرير لصحيفه واشنطن بوست
الامريكيه التي كشفت ان مسؤولين امريكيين
اخبار القاده الاوكرانيين انهم يواجهون
لحظه حرجه لتغيير مسار الحرب
التدريبات الاخيره التي نقلتها الصحيفه
حمل الضمنيا دعوه امريكيه لاوكرانيا
بضروره تحقيق النصر في المعارك المقبله
لان الدعم المستمر الذي حظيت به اوكرانيا
قد يتراجع فهو اشارت الى عدم استعدادها
لمواصله هذا الدعم لاوكرانيا بالاسلحه
بشكل دائم
[موسيقى]
لا تزال معركه بخموت تحظى بالاميه الاكبر
ميدانيا والى الان لم تسقط المدينه في يد
موسكو كليا رغم الافضليه الواضحه لقوتها
على ارض الميدان كليب بنفسها اعترفت ان
الوضع معقد شمال مخمود مركز المعارك في
شرق البلاد ويواصل الجيش الروسي تطويق
المدينه حيث يسيطر مؤخرا على اكرام غور
وهي بلده صغيره تبعد حوالي 9 كم من بخموت
معركه بخموت هي الاعنف والاطول منذ بدء
الهجوم الروسي ضد اوكرانيا هجمات روسيه
متتاليه برا وقصف مدفعي وجوي حذر معه
الناتو من ان روسيا تمهد لهجوم كبير قبل
ايام من مرور عام على بدء الحرب
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه قالت ان مجموعه
فاجنر الروسيه حققت انتصارات محدوده في
الضواحي الشماليه لباخمت وحسب مركز دراسات
الحرب الامريكي تعمل القوات الروسيه على
الاستيلاء على قريه افنفيسكي بعد
كريسنالورا حيث يدور قتال عنيف على الطريق
السريع واصبحت بلده الشاسيفيار الحصن
الاخير امام القوات الروسيه لدخول باخموت
بينما حفرت اوكرانيا انفاقا حولها لمنع
تقدم الروس وقالت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
ان القوات الروسيه تبدل تكتيكاتها
باستمرار فاحيانا تشن هجوما بمجموعات
صغيره وتاره تستخدم عشرات الاشخاص
المستنفرين في هجوم اخر بينما تكثف القصف
الليلي بالصواريخ
نيويورك تايمز نقلت عن مسؤولين اوكرانيين
مطالبه دول الناتو بذخائر للدبابات
وقذائف مدفعيه للقاذفات الغربيه لمواجهه
الهجوم الروسي الواسع كما طالبوا بطائرات
مقاتله
الوضع الراهن في اوكرانيا بمثابه اختبار
لامتلاك زمام المبادره ليس فقط لكييف
وانما لحلف الناتو ايضا الذي يخوض سباقا
لوجستيا مع روسيا قبل معركه اوسع
رنا الى ان الولايات المتحده تدرس ارسال
الاف الاسلحه لاوكرانيا سبق وان صدرتها من
ايران قبل ان تصل للحوثيين حيث قال
مسؤولون امريكيون للصحيفه انهم يتطلعون
لارسال المزيد الى اوكرانيا من ضمنها اكثر
من 5000 بندقيه هجوميه ومليون وستمائه الف
طلقه وعدد قليل من الصواريخ المضاده
للدبابات
قال الجيش الامريكي انه اسقط طائره مسيره
ايرانيه الصنع في سوريا امس القياده
المركزيه الامريكيه نشرت على تويتر صوره
لطائره الايرانيه المسيره تظهر اشتعال
النيران فيها بعد استهدافها موضحه ان
المسيره الايرانيه كانت تحاول استطلاع
قاعده دوريات في شمال شرق سوريا
الى ذلك قدمت الحكومه البريطانيه ادله
للامم المتحده تفيد بتهاك ايران لقراري
مجلس الامن بشان اليمن واشار البيان
البريطاني الى ان الادله تثبت وجود صله
مباشره بين طهران وتهريب انظمه الصواريخ
والطائرات المسيره للحوثيين بجانب تهريب
شحنات صواريخ ارض جو وقطع صواريخ روز
يستخدمها الحوثيون لمهاجمه السعوديه
والامارات
وهذه الساعه الاخباريه متواصله مع حضراتكم
ولدينا
البيت الابيض يستبعد ارتباط الاجسام التي
تم اسقاطها ببرنامج تجسس صيني
نواصل مع حضراتكم تقديم هذه النشره اكد
البيت الابيض انه لا توجد مؤشرات حتى الان
الى ان ثلاثه اجسام طائره اسقطت في امريكا
الصينيه او مخصصه للتجسس واضاف البيت
الابيض انه لم تعلن اي جهه مسؤوليه عن
الاجسام الثلاثه التي تم اسقاطها
اجواء الولايات المتحده ملبده باجسام
غامضه اربعه اجسام وبالون صيني وثلاثه
اجسام اخرى حلقت في سمائها تحركات دفعت
سلاح الجو الامريكي الى اسقاطها ومن ثم
تكثيف عمليات الرصد والبحث عن اي انشطه في
السماء قد تحمل صبغه استخباراتيه اذ تم
تغيير اليه عمل الرادارات الامريكيه بعد
اسقاط البالون الصيني ووفقا لقياده الدفاع
الجوي الامريكي اصبحت رادارات ترصد اجسام
طيران اصغر وابطى حركه بعدما كانت ترصد
فقط الطائرات والقاذفات السريعه حاله
التنبيه العاليه اصبحت ترصد بدقه الاجسام
الاصغر والابطا والتي تنتج ترددات عرضيه
منخفضه للغايه على الرغم من ان الولايات
المتحده لم تتمكن من تحديد ماهيه الاجسام
الغامضه الاخيره الا ان قرار اسقاطها من
تزايد المخاوف من عمل استخباراتي يستهدف
منشاتها العسكريه خاصه بعد واقعه البالون
الصيني اما بكين فما زالت ترفض اتهامها
اطلاق بالون تجسسي على منشات عسكريه
امريكيه معربه عن تغاضيها عن وقائع مماثله
منذ العام الماضي حلقت بالونات امريكيه
عاليه الارتفاع فوق الفضاء الجوي الصيني
دون اذن من الصين احدى عشره مره تعاملنا
معها بمهنيه ومسؤوليه لتظل اجواء العلاقات
بين امريكا والصين مشحونه ومملوءه بالحذر
عسكريا وسياسيا وفي الواجهه منها حمايه
الاجواء الجويه من اي رصد استخباراتي
علي السمان العربيه
الامم المتحده انك هيليا رسميا ترشحها
لخوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه في الولايات
المتحده وطلبت هيلي في رسالتها بجيل جديد
من القاده منتقده الجمهوريين في
الانتخابات الاخيره التي يدخل فيها ترامب
وعمره 76 عاما السباق مجددا عنك
ترشح نفسها لخوض انتخابات الرئاسه
الامريكيه لتصبح اول مرشحه بارزه تنافس
دونالد ترامب
تبلغ من العمر 51 عاما من اصول هنديه
المندوبه السابقه لامريكا في الامم
المتحده تنتمي للحزب الجمهوري
ثالث شخص من اصل هندي يحاول الفوز
بالانتخابات اول امراه تحكم ولايه
كارولاينا الجنوبيه
قضت محكمه تونسيه بحبس القياديه في حركه
النهضه نور الدين البحيري بسبب اتهامات
تتعلق بما وصفته اعتداء لمحاوله تبديل
هيئه الدوله وقال محامي الدفاع هيئه
الدفاع عن البحيري في تصريحات اذاعيه ان
قرارها حبس موكله جاء على خلفيه تصريح
ادلى به في تحرك نظمته جبهه الخلاص في
الثامن من يناير الثاني الماضي
الرجل الثاني في حركه النهضه الاخوانيه
نور الدين البحيري رهن الايقاف من قبل
الاجهزه الامنيه ومعه رجل الاعمال التونسي
المثير للجدل كمال لطيف والناشط السياسي
خيام التركي وغيره من رجال الاعمال
والقضاه والكوادر الامنيه السلطات
القضائيه التونسيه تتكتم عن اسباب
الايقافات فيما بعد التقارير الاعلاميه
تتحدث عن تهام تتعلق بالتامر على امن
الدوله هذه اللقافات ويعتبرها مسار فعلي
انطلاقه فعليه لمسار المحاسبه باعتبار بطء
هذا المسار باعتبار الخطوات التي لم تكن
بالشكل المطلوب خلال سنه ونص الفارطه هي
مجموعه من اللقافات حسب التهم تتعلق تامر
على امن الدوله وهذا ربما ثابت من خلال
نوعيه الايقافات نوعيه الاشخاص العسكريين
ليسوا سياسيين فقط ان الشعب يريد المحاسبه
ولابد من محاسبه هؤلاء
كل هؤلاء ولا استثناء لاحد مهما كان
ويسر الرئيس سعيد على ضروره المحاسبه
كمطلب شعبي بينما تندد احزاب المعارضه
بالايقافات معتبره اياها تضيقا على
الرافدين لمسار الخامس والعشرين من يوليو
تمت خيط فاصل ورفيع جدا بين المحاسبه وبين
التصفيه الحسابات او تصفيه الخصوم
المحاسبه هو المطلب الاكبر للشعب التونسي
بل هو المطلب الذي جعل التونسيون على
الاقل في 25 جويليه يصطفون وراء رئيس
الجمهوريه عمليه المحاسبه كانت خطاها
بطيئه جدا والرئيس قيس سعيد فسر الامر على
اساس ان القضاء او جسم القضاء في تونس
يستعصي على القيام بدوره او يستعصي على
الاصلاح ويؤكد متابعون ان دائره الايقافات
ستتوسع مستقبلا خاصه مع اعاده فتح عدد من
الملفات على غرار الارهاب والتسفير
والاغتيالات السياسيه يؤكد جل المتابعين
للمشهد التونسي ان تواتر الايقافات
الاخيره فيما يشبه تساقط قطع الدومينو
ستعقبه وتتبعات قضائيه تجسيدا لمبدا
المحاسبه وتحقيق العداله والقطع مع
الافلات من
ملحوثيه والحصار على تعز عشرات النسوه في
المدينه الى الانخراط في سوق العمل
وممارسه اعمال شقه كانت حكرا على الرجال
قبل الحرب من اجل اعاله اسرهم
في السوق هذا المزدحم بالباعه تتقاسم ام
جنات مع الرجال مشقه العمل ومن اجل ان
تحصل على عشرين دولار لسد رمق الاطفال
يتوجب عليها يوميا بيع اكثر من 70 قرصا من
الخبز المعروف بالقدم كفاح مع لقمه العيش
تقول الفتى لا يسمح لها بمغادره المكان
قبل ان تفرغ الكميه التي في حوزتها
علشان اني صعوبه الحياه عيالي اشتري حق
ايجار بيت اشتري حق
ما اكل ومشرب اني اعين نفسي من نفسي ما
فيش من يعيلني مصير فراق قاس اذا القى
بثقه على ام جنات وحشرها مع اطفالها
الثلاثه في غرفه ضيقه بدت مسكنهم الوحيد
بعد ان هجرهم المعيز فلا شيء يصحبهم في
حجرتهم هذه سوى فقر اثقل كاهلهم منذ اعوام
كبقيه اسر في المدينه
كانها قبر قبر عن اياك يعني
بنفس الوقت حتى لما اقوم اصلي ما فيش نفس
حتى للسكاده والله انني اصلي ولمن عيالي
والله العظيم انني اصلي لبن ارجو لعيالي
مرهق جدا البحث عن القوت اليومي في
المدينه المحاصره هذه فعلى ارصفه الشوارع
تصف عشرات النسوه بحثا عما يسد الرمق
خصوصا من فقدنا ازواجهن في الحرب
زوجي ما تتوفين معي ثلاثه جهال يعني
اطلب الله على عيالي وتشور تقارير امميه
الى ان اكثر من عشرين مليون شخص في اليمن
اي ما يعادل سبعين في المئه من اجمل
السكان بحاجه ماسه للمساعده الانسانيه كم
يصعب اذا على ساكنه هذه المدينه الحصول
على لقمه العيش في ظل الحرب والحصار
الحوثي فالاسواق هذه تكتظ بالعديد من
الباعه جميعهم يعيشون الضنك الحياه خصوصا
النساء والاطفال الذين اجبروا على
الانخراط في سوق العمل لاعاده اسرهم هل
سعيد العربيه تعز
ختام هذه الساعه الاخباريه مع ابرز
عناوينها
انقاذوا سيده تركيه تبلغ من العمر 77 عاما
بعد تسعه ايام من الزلزال مع تواصل عمليات
رفع الانقاض
دخول اول قافله مساعدات امميه عبر معبر
باب السلامه الحدودي بين تركيا ومناطق
سيطره المعارضه في شمال سوريا
روسيا ترد على تقارير تتهموها باحتجاز
اطفال اوكرانيين بالقوه وتقول انها
استقبلته مع اسرهم بعد فرارهم من القص
الجيش الامريكي يعلنوا اسقاط طائره مسيره
ايرانيه الصنع في سوريا كانت تحاول
استطلاع قاعده دوريات في شمال شرق البلاد
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]